in society there's really three groups
of guys there are the Chads the simps
and the sexless and this is how I'm
going to divide it now the Chads
typically are the guys that bang all the
chicks and I've always said that the
Chads have the most honest view of women
because the Chads are the best looking
most successful guys that they've seen
the worst of women they've seen wives
cheat on their husbands with them
they've they've seen women that you
would think our good girls go home with
them on the first night so it's
interesting if you talk to a guy that
gets laid a lot or just has been with a
ton of women he just has a really
different View